you
because if you do a school like 30 only
let's say half are going to
okay fine
how i'm just doing how many school
things
us 20 21
school things how many
34 school shootings all my days that's
death their injury is 68. that is too
much why is that out of hell that's like
that's like not that many uh how many
people how many 300 how many people in
the uk though
329 million people in the us
how would they regulate guns in this big
of a country in a freaking alaska what
are you gonna do in alaska but how many
why how many school shootings in the uk
i bet probably less you guys don't have
guys zero but you guys look at look at
uk uk look at uk map
you're telling me this is this is what
you got you guys are on a freaking
island yeah but we've got zero
see
how many stabbings yeah you guys have
more stabbings yeah we have a lot of
stabbing it's harder to get going
okay what does it matter if you're dying
yeah but it's gang related
but you're talking about school students
people don't just go and start knifing
up schools
well yeah because they can't shoot as
many people yeah people don't do it okay
okay are there not teenagers that get
knives and stab each other yeah i'm gang
stuff yeah that's not related but they
don't go into a school and be like oh
hello
replacement period
homicide
is it i don't actually know
500 oh that's not even bad 500 they're
in 594 homicide victims
oh ending in march yeah i don't think
that's for the whole week oh yeah there
you go that can't be
i don't know so do you five nine four
times twelve should i just do 20 20.
so is it like they do it march to march
or is it 695 just can't be just murders
and that's only two two a day
in the whole of the uk okay so you don't
think that's right so you're saying
i don't know what that sounds quite low
if i'm honest
yeah i don't know
because my little my little town that i
used to live in
used to average free stabbings a week
oh okay so
oh murder rate well yeah here we go here
we go this is what i'm looking for
murder rate by country
okay so
you guys are not in the lowest murder
rate so humble yourself
humble yourself
you know some of them live under sharia
law though look at sharia law yeah
oh here we go where are you guys at i
just want to see if we're we're still in
the blue though you lot in the red oh
damn
that's cause you lot have guns
i don't think so wait i want to look
down
so oh you guys are purple yeah you're
purple
where are you guys is this you guys here
yeah we're purple
oh yeah you got a red hmm
do you think it's for real because we
have guns yeah i don't think it's
because we have guns
we'll hover up there we'll tell you the
homicide right hover over england and it
tells you
where
it tells you that so the homicide
it's okay so it's lower than
809
you have five times the amount of people
and you have sixteen thousand deaths
yeah that's not like crazy that's not
looking good you ass just looking mad
and she's asking actually have guns i
don't think so
april oh i see australia yeah australia
is big but they get more guns now
australia they've got mad they've got
gun laws which should restrict it it's
interesting though because in the u.s
the cities with the most gun control
have higher crime rates i can be i can
believe that all right
that the knife-wielding maniac that you
saw is not who she really was maybe in
that moment she was trying to kill
somebody but the point that we should be
focused on is that mikaya bryant
liked to promote peace in her spare time
right i mean this is like
i feel like we have now tapped in to
fiction like now we have to just accept
fiction it doesn't matter because makaya
bryant was black and she died at the
hands of a police officer and that's all
that matters now people want to come out
and they want to support micaiah bryant
maybe she too like george floyd will be
buried into a gold casket maybe
eventually one day nancy pelosi will say
that mikaya ryan's name will be
synonymous synonymous with justice
let me tell you what is actually
happening in america at this time if
you're a black american you better pay
attention
right now in america the goal is to make
sure that black people
love and support criminality
that is the goal the express goal now is
to make black people believe that we
should be in the streets rioting and
looting and demanding justice for
criminals right because that is what
these people are they're criminals
george floyd was in the process of
committing a crime i'm not saying he
deserved to die i don't think anybody
deserved die i think he deserved to be
arrested they attempted to arrest him
did you forget that part have you seen
the full video of his arrest the media
refuses to show the full video that
shows the police tried to put him into
the vehicle multiple times and he
resisted arrest by saying i'm
claustrophobic i'm claustrophobic
because he had just ingested fentanyl
fentanyl that thing that's a hundred
times more potent than morphine but then
you come to a point of duty of care is
that the guy was high on drugs wherever
he's made that mistake but to equate
that that it's almost she's putting on
it's his fault that he died is is
i don't think she's fair to say that
that's
that's not either that's not a hero
there's like any other crime if if
someone was graped you'd never say to
them ah but they were walking out late
at night or they're wearing that type of
clothing so for this kind of crime
why is that used as a supplement to me
our kids
some
unlawful word lost their life i would
well for grape
yeah i mean i think there's situations
you shouldn't put yourself in as a woman
and it's not something
i hate it just like i don't think it's
smart to resist arrest yeah i don't
think it's my either what i'm saying is
she's almost trying to use that as an
argument and when if you had to switch
it to great i guarantee most of society
wouldn't allow that as an argument if
most of but we're in the free thinking
space here
and i i would never blame someone but i
would say hey
you can look at that situation and think
maybe don't put yourself in that
situation yeah like everyone knows that
yeah that wears that goes out and has no
way she's getting home like she doesn't
know how she's getting yeah and it's
like if you go out at night wearing
nothing that's like
i'm not saying like what do you think is
gonna happen but like honestly if you're
by yourself you don't have a guy to
protect you like what but can you see my
argument because even though we are in
the freeze thinking space can you see
how people are allowed this is an
argument but if you change it to grape
people would be like oh my god how could
she ever make this argument
i can see what you're saying i just
don't think like
it's right
because i just i think like you
shouldn't resist arrest from an officer
yeah and it puts both of you at risk
because now the officer like
you see in so many of these cases people
resisting arrest yeah i wouldn't do that
yeah it's just not smart
so
like i had a cousin that was addicted to
drugs and he had some bad interactions
with the police but i was like you know
what he's also crackhead
like like a lot of the [ __ ] that like
people complain